what happens if they do categorize
bitcoin as a security well bitcoin's not
a security
right we've already we've already
crossed that chasm the point the real
question you should be asking yourself
is what happens if they categorize
ethereum and every other crypto as a
security
you're underestimating the power of
politicians to screw things up
you're underestimating the the power of
them not liking a person like you to get
up and say whatever you want to say
and you offend them you offend
politicians you know people who are yeah
i've just read an article right now from
political can you pull up the political
article it's just the way they get that
but the real point here is there's 17
000 cryptos and and all the rest are
much more centralized so yeah but they
know the most powerful one is the one
that you're you're supporting and the
reason it's powerful is because it's
completely decentralized and and no one
nation state can shut it down not even
all of them could shut it down if they
wanted to
so so so you so these uh
sweet amazing nice
kind
uh supportive people who love
independent thinkers like you
politicians
you don't think behind closed doors
they're sitting there trying to figure
out a way to
regulate or get their hands on bitcoin
because they're starting to lose a
little control with the bitcoin because
the bitcoin community essentially the
crypto community forget you know let's
just say bitcoin one side and the crypto
community
i said this the other day i i think it's
becoming a political party i think the
cryptocurrency yeah so regulations the
party
first of all there's like 250 million
people
that are that are pro bitcoin right now
and this is spreading at millions per
week
so
you can't find you can't find
any large constituency that's anti right
it's a virus that's spreading
right you're not going to get any votes
by being against bitcoin right there is
no constituency that is anti-bitcoin
second regulations not bad right
sometimes people say oh they're going to
regulate is bad now the truth of the
matter is the faster the regulation
comes the faster the 17 000 other
cryptos get sorted into their buckets as
securities platforms art etc
and that will actually shake out
a lot of the noise in the system result
in a lot of capital focusing upon the
winner which is bitcoin
and it'll also accelerate the entry of
institutional capital into the space
because there's a hundred trillion
dollars worth of money that's not in the
crypto space that's afraid to come into
the space because they're not sure about
the definitions between the securities
the funds that's a valid concern
property yeah that's a valid concern so
in fact the regulation probably would be
the best thing that ever happened i've
seen you say that yeah can i read a
quote that you've actually said yeah um
this is on page four bitcoin evangelist
michael saylor says clear crypto
regulations would speed
institutional adoption so cnbc story
tighter government crypto regulations
would actually be a positive catalyst
for bitcoin micro strategy co-founder
michael saylor says additional regular
regulatory insights on what the
regulation is well yeah that's what i
wanted to clarify it says additional
regulatory clarity from the biden
administration is going to going to
benefit bitcoin and accelerate
institutional adoption of that asset
stressing
a major bitcoin believer and holder he's
looking for clear bright line
definitions of digital property versus a
digital security versus a digital
currency and the operating rules of the
digital digital exchange
you know you know you said something you
said there's 250 million people that are
pro crypto
right or pro bitcoin but 250 million
probably more after this week okay right
we probably made 200 million fans i
don't disagree but i think there's i
think because of ukraine yeah but not
just ukraine canada there's a lot of
different things that's going on but but
here's what i would also say michael
there's
seven and a half billion people in the
world that are pro-freedom
except for the people that are
pro-communism and control you're
underestimating the power don't you
think because we're part of the same
party
under thinking but don't you think we're
underestimating the power of the few who
hate independent thinkers who go make
their money and they're sitting around
you know constantly advancing and
questioning them and
in a way cryptocurrency is a big middle
finger to all the politicians
and they don't want to have 250 million
middle fingers right so how do you
how do you address that part amongst
these few that like to control people
like you it looks like it looks like
bitcoin's winning
if we if we look at what's happening
bitcoin is spreading everywhere in the
world it's only been a few years
right i mean it's it's the most
powerful disruptive force in the decade
you know look at look at the rate at
which it's spreading 0 to 250 million
people
and if you turn on cnbc and watch i you
know count the number of minutes that'll
go by before you'll see the bitcoin
ticker flip up on the screen or before
they'll start talking about it
as far as i can see the idea of
the idea of bitcoin and the idea of
digital property and digital money and
and uh and
digital freedom
is spreading pretty aggressively
very aggressively um i i don't really so
much worry about it because um
i mean i
i've met with
a lot of people including a lot of
politicians i think you might find
one
out of 20 that will be trollish that'll
be negative because they think it gets
them attention
but
if you speak to most people in private
there are they all think it's a pretty
good idea i think i think you probably
find a lot of uh a lot of advocates in
russia right now a lot of advocate
remember what happened when when putin
or when the when the russian bank said
they were going to ban it then all of a
sudden they reversed their stance within
24 hours
right you see the same thing happening
in every single other place in the world
if you look at the senate and congress
there's
the consensus in uh congress right now
is
is very pro crypto and it's very pro
bitcoin it's not anti if you look at the
administration the administration is
moving forward uh with uh with
guidelines that will be beneficial to
the industry
there is a schism between the
institutions and the entrepreneurs by
the way
like for example
if jp morgan can issue a stable coin
then the existing stablecoin issuers
would view that as being competitive to
them so there's a lot of tension between
institutions and entrepreneurs and
between states and federal government
but i don't think anybody disagrees with
the idea that uh that bitcoin's here to
stay and this is spreading
there's a and so i'm not i'm not much
worried about it but look
you can choose to be pessimistic and say
oh yeah well somebody somebody somewhere
will take it away because it's too good
an idea but what are you gonna do roll
over and die i don't think it's
pessimism you you started your company
in 89
and you went public in 98 you got a
10 million dollar deal with mcdonald's
in 92
from 1990 to 96 your company grew out
100 every year from getting these facts
right you come from an era where andy
grove was god and andy grove wrote a
book where he ran intel i think they ran
the company at what pace they were
growing he wrote a book only the
paranoid survive so there's a difference
between pessimism
and paranoia
the paranoia from a few
uh comes from supporting the cause of
crypto nobody's sitting there saying i
mean in so many ways this makes sense
it's tough to argue this who doesn't
want to not be controlled by the bank i
can't think of any time where bank has
been the low income middle income or the
average guy's best friend who's ever
liked the bank i don't think any time
anybody's ever liked the bank the low to
middle income in the rich unless when
the rich was just getting money without
you know what you're talking about it's
being printed i'm just my skepticism is
to be a little bit paranoid about what
these politicians who sit around
uh uh wanting their names to be on a
bill and a law that can regulate to brag
about it that's the only you know
paranoia that exists and the rational
response to that is go educate the world
so if you go to hope.com bitcoin is hope
go to hope.com there's courses and books
and educational materials on bitcoin
if you go to my website sailor.org we've
got a free bitcoin for everybody course
we've given it to
tens of thousands of people
um why do you think i'm sitting here
talking to you today but i think to
level above that though if i if i was
arrogant and presumptuous i just sit
back and wait for the inevitable to take
place but
i don't think uh i don't think we can
sit back and wait i think we got to go
and speak with every politician every
influencer we got to reach out to every
community
you got to go on television you know go
on cnbc fox cnn you know bloomberg
and educate
look
bitcoin is is the digital transformation
of and we are living through the digital
transformation of property money and
energy
and and once you understand this idea
digital transformation of property money
and energy
you realize that you know the world's
not going to understand that for a
decade i mean it'll take 10 years 15 20
years before people get their hands
around what is that i mean it's so
inconceivable
if you go back 100 years and you look at
electricity
how long did it take before people
really understood the concept of
electric energy
can't touch it right without getting
shocked by it but it was a scary thing
by the way it was regulated
right it was regulated and and uh it
took a long time for people to embrace
it and it changed the entire world
the same happened with
chemical energy in the form of standard
oil
it was regulated took a long time for
people to appreciate it aviation air
power nuclear power all of these things
you know
digital energy is cyber power bitcoin is
cyber power right the next war will be
fought in cyberspace if you don't master
digital energy you're not going to win
it you can't even defend against it so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]